raider nation is out in full force
tonight the raiders versus the ravens
the game kicks off just about 20 minutes
you're looking live at a legion stadium
packed with fans ready to cheer on our
home team good evening to you thank you
for joining us on eight news now at five
i'm brian loftis and i'm kirsten joyce
in for denise we have got a packed show
for you so let's get right to it we've
got team coverage on all things raiders
from tailgating fans to road closures to
watch out for there's our entire team
we're going to start with sports
director chris matthews kicking off with
a look at tonight's match-up hey chris
well how you doing guys i'll tell you
what it's exciting time here this is
darren waller's 29th birthday by the way
so how great would it be to celebrate
your 29th birthday with a win over the
baltimore ravens lots of question marks
surrounding this game how's that
offensive line going to be it's been
revamped josh jacobs will he play is he
healthy is he ready to go what about
that new gus bradley defense with the
two
newcomers kj wright and of course denzel
perryman those are two new guys that are
going to be there and you got three
rookies playing tonight three rookies
that were just drafted in the last draft
in april alex leatherwood's going to be
there hobbs is going to be playing and
trayvon morrick so it's going to be an
interesting interesting game here with
the baltimore ravens who by the way
lamar jackson was a 2019
uh nfl mvp so they're going to try to
contain lamar jackson well over here my
shoulder here this is the raiders bus
right here you got lots of fun stuff
going on here the raiders bus i want to
show you right here on this door right
here where it says the item win of
course that is the raiders fame the
autumn win and two years ago i met tony
in oakland for the last raiders game
there and this guy right here is all
decked out but he's got a horn and he
plays that raider steam give us a big 20
seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
and this is what you find this kind of
stuff right here there it is right there
the baltimore ravens cap right here the
ravens capped so a lot of fun here but
there's more this place is packed with
raider fans raider nation all
surrounding the legion stadium so let's
go to iran few trail with much more on
some of those raider nation tailgaters
hey ron
yes indeed chris okay we're about two
blocks away maybe a block and a half
from a legion stadium right here you can
see it just
to the left here where a tailgate party
fan fast vegas is taking place in a
watch party most people are inside but
we convinced one guy to hang out with us
for a little while bob golick let's see
your sign over there says three-time pro
bowler two-time all-pro 22 and a half
career sacks which is well over a sack a
year and a national championship with
notre dame national championship notre
dame i wrestled in high school and
college and
why do you keep hitting me
like pokemon movie acting
sorry staging the screen okay allegiance
we're seeing it right there does that
amaze you to think this this monday
night football in vegas we're seeing the
raiders your raiders play a football
game here i never thought they would see
a team an nfl team end up in vegas i
mean we were told every year if anybody
calls you
and says hey win this game by 10 points
which
who's going to do that
exactly but they were very
very aware of gambling and stuff and and
now we're i'm watching these network
games or shows and they have like
they have like betting people on yeah
ravens are four and a half point
favorites we all know that now it's like
it's like crazy but you know it is what
it is and there's a huge
i didn't realize that the the the amount
of people in the metroplex here was so
big it's like over a million people i
believe i thought it was just going to
be transient people in and out for the
gaming but in cleveland yet but we're
getting big i know most of cleveland's
here now so
bob going to dry heat
smoking thank you for joining us here
live a lot of the fans are inside
fanfest vegas the game's getting set to
kick off here in just about 15 minutes
so let's go back to the studio